>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
BETWEEN AMERICAN POLITICIANS AND
OPERATIVES FROM FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
INSTEAD, SO FAR THE
MISMANAGED.
NEWLY RELEASED TEXTS FROM PETER
STRZOK SUGGESTED HIGH LEVEL FBI
VERY BEGINNING.
FOX CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORR
RESPONSIBILITY
RESPONSIBILIT
-SPONSIBILIT
--PONSIBILIT
-- ONSIBILIT
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE HERRIDGE
HAS MORE.
>> ONE SENIOR INVESTIGATOR WAS
SKEPTICAL THE RUSSIA PROBE WOULD
UNCOVER WRONG DOING.
AFTER ROBERT MUELLER TOOK OVER
MERITS.
A SENSE OF UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
UNLEASHED IT WITH MYE, THE CODE
MANE FOR THE CLINTON E-MAIL
IT.
ANOTHER REPUBLICAN THAT READ THE
TEXT SAID THE FBI OFFICIALS TALK
ABOUT A SECRET SOCIETY WITHIN
DAYS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
VICTORY.
>> THERE WAS A SOCIETY OF AT
LEAST TWO PEOPLE TO INCLUDE
PETER STRZOK AND LISA PAGE THAT
HAD A DESIRE TO KEEP DONALD
TRUMP FROM BECOMING PRESIDENT
AND THEN AN EXPRESSED INTENT TO
WORK AGAINST HIM AFTER HE WAS
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
>> IF FBI BLAMES A TECHNICAL FOR
A FIVE-MONTH GAP IN TEXTS FROM
CAN BE COVERED.
>> Tucker: THANKS, CATHERINE.
JOE, THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: ON SPECIAL REPORT A
LITTLE OVER AN HOUR AGO, RON
JOHNSON, THE HEAD OF SENATOR --
THE SECRET SOCIETY MAY HAVE MET
OFF SITE AWAY FROM THE FBI
SECRETLY.
WHAT MORE IS THIS?
>> I SUGGESTS THAT THERE WAS A
BRAZEN PLOT TO ILLEGALLY
TO FRAME DONALD TRUMP WITH A
FALSELY-CREATED CRIME.
EVERYTHING WE'VE SEEN FROM THE
TEXTS AND FROM ALL OF THE FACTS
DEVELOPING SHOWS THAT THE FBI
AND SENIOR DOJ OFFICIALS
CONSPIRED TO VIOLATE THE LAW AND
TO DENY DONALD TRUMP HIS CIVIL
RIGHTS.
>> Tucker: WHAT WOULD BE THE
MOTIVE FOR THAT?
>> THE MOTIVE IS THAT I DIDN'T
BE PRESIDENT AND THEY WERE GOING
TO DO EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER
TO EXONERATE HILLARY CLINTON AND
THEY DIDN'T THINK HE SHOULD BE
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THE CLAIM THAT FIVE MONTHS OF
>> AS AN OLD UNITED STATES
ATTORNEY, THAT EXPLANATION FROM
THE BUREAU IS LUDICROUS.
THOSE TEXTS WERE PURPOSELY
DESTROYED, PERIOD.
THEY WERE PURPOSELY DESTROYED.
MOREOVER, THEY EXIST SOMEWHERE.
I CAN ASSURE YOU THE NSA HAS
THEM.
IF THE BUREAU CAN'T FIGURE OUT
WERE.
>> Tucker: SO YOU DON'T BUY IT
THOSE TEXTS EXIST.
IF THEY DON'T EXIST, THAT I WERE
DESTROYED.
>> Tucker: SO YOU USE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
HOW DO WE PROCEED IF THE
COUNTRY'S CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS GUILTY OF THAT?
>> THE ATTORNEY GENERAL NEEDS TO
APPOINT A SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IF HE DOESN'T WANT TO DO THAT,
HE NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THE
JURIRY UNDER OATH, COMEY,
STRZOK, PAGE, BAKER, McCABE AND
SENIOR JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS, SALLY YET, BRUCE OHR
IN FRONT OF A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY.
THIS.
FRAME DONALD TRUMP OF A
FALSELY-CREATED CRIME.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANY
EMPANELLED THAT INVESTIGATION?
>> I CERTAINLY HOPE SO.
I HOPE THEY HAVE.
THEY'RE NOT ABOUT TO DO SO
SHORTLY.
>> Tucker: WHY IS IT SO HARD FOR
THE FBI TO LE RESPOND TO
OVERSIGHTE
OVERSIGHTED
OVERSIGHTED?
>> IT SHOULDN'T BE.
CHRISTOPHER WRAY'S PERFORMANCE
RESPOND TO CONGRESS.
IT'S BEEN AN ABYSMAL PERFORMANCE
BY DIRECTOR WRAY.
>> Tucker: AND DOES IT STRIKE
YOU ODD?
>> VERY ODD.
I CANNOT CONCEIVE OF
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH AGENTS
EXCHANGED, KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW
NOW ABOUT THE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
INVOLVING THE COMPROMISING OF
NATIONAL SECURITY AGENCY
INTERCEPTS OF 702 DATA INVOLVING
PRIVATE AMERICAN CITIZENS, I
FOR CLASSIFIED INFORMATION?
>> I CAN'T SEE HOW.
>> Tucker: BUT THEY HAVE PRESENT
COLLEAGUES IN THE BUILDING.
>> MEMBERS OF THE SECRET SOCIETY
NO DOUBT TALK TO EACH OTHER.
>> Tucker: HOW CAN THAT BE AT
THIS POINT?
>> I'M AFRAID ONLY CHRISTOPHER
WRAY KNOWS WHY THEY'RE BEING A
LOUED TO STAY IN THE BUILDING.
>> Tucker: LAST QUESTION SINCE
YOU'VE BEEN HERE A LONG TIME AND
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM WATCHING
NOW WHERE THE FBI HAS LOST
ALMOST ALL OF ITS CREDIBILITY
AND REGRETTABLY ITS INTEGRITY AS
A RESULT OF THE CONDUCT OF JAMES
COMEY WHO REMAINS AMERICA'S MOST